[CREAK]
[WHOOSH]
[TAPPING]
FILIP BABA: All right,
so welcome, everyone,
to our Bose AR Unity workshop.
My name is Filip Baba.
I'm a senior developer
advocate at Bose.
So what that means basically
is I work with developers,
enabling them to build
experiences for our platform.
I host workshops.
We do game jams,
hackathons, also public
speaking on behalf
of the platform.
And if you do end up
building something with Base
AR Unity SDK specifically--
I'm on the Unity side--
you'll most likely
be talking to me,
and I'll be helping you get your
idea and your product out there
and trying to
bring Bose on board
to help you out with
that as much as possible.
So I am your voice when
it comes to these things.
So I'm just going
to talk a little bit
briefly about what is Bose AR.
Some of you may
already know or not,
but I'm just going
to get into it.
So we have a new concept
called audio augmented reality.
Now, many of you
probably already heard
about augmented reality.
First thing you
probably think about
is hololens or ARKit ARCore,
Magic Leap, stuff like that.
So we are actually audio
first augmented reality.
Now, what that means
is, think spatial audio,
for example, where
you have sounds
placed in space around you,
and you're kind of virtually
hearing it spatially.
So what enables us to do
audio augmented reality
are the sensors that are
located in each of these Bose AR
wearables.
You'll have a pair
of frames, but then
we also have our
headphones as well,
which have the same
sets of sensors in them.
And those sensors are
an accelerometer, which
allows you to get impulse
and sudden movements;
a gyroscope, which tracks
rotation, so typically what
we use the gyro for is to track
the user's head orientation;
and magnetometer, which
is basically a compass,
and we use that for
our navigation apps.
So if you know the GPS position
of a user based on their phone,
and if you use the
magnetic heading
from where their head is
actually like pointing at,
you can know what they're
looking at on a map
pretty accurately, actually.
So we have gestures as
well on our devices.
So the frames specifically
have an input gesture here
on the right side.
It's a double tap, so
it's not a specific, touch
sensitive sensor.
It's actually based
on the accelometer,
so it's the little impulse tap.
And the tap actually
works from any side,
but it's recommended to
do it from the right side
because that's where
the sensor kit is.
We also have custom
gestures that we actually
encourage our
developers to explore,
and it's a mixture
of the other sensors.
So a custom gesture
would be something
like, you're creating
an experience,
and it tells you, look
up, and you look up,
and then you track
that rotation change.
That would be a custom gesture.
I know some of the games
that have been built,
sometimes, it tells you
to duck, and there's
a bullet flying over you
or something like that.
So that would be
a custom gesture.
So Heads Up Hands Free is one
of the models that we have.
So the idea behind it
Heads Up Hands Free
is, a lot of the applications
today, whether they're
AR or just standard
mobile applications,
you're always staring
at your phone.
You're always walking around.
Your neck as a little
craned because you're always
looking down at your phone.
The whole idea behind
Heads Up Hands Free
is that we want to create
applications that you don't
have to stare at your phone.
The input is the wearable,
and the output also
goes through the wearable.
So you don't actually have
to look at a screen for most
of these activities.
So I'll give you an example.
Let's say NaviGuide,
for example.
What it does is it knows
your GPS location based
on a mobile device,
and it knows you're
heading based on where you're
looking with the magnetometer.
So what it can do
is then it can tell
you're looking at this
restaurant, for example,
or this cafe.
You double tap
the input gesture,
and it'll actually
pull a Yelp review.
Now, think about the non
Heads Up Hands Free way
of pulling up a Yelp review.
What are you doing?
You're most likely
googling the name,
or you're typing in
the street address.
But it requires you to pull
out your phone, launch the app,
find a name, type it in or the
address or the pin on the map,
and then you get to
that Yelp review.
It takes you out of
what you're doing.
So if you want to look up five
or six restaurants walking down
the street, you're basically
probably staring at your phone
for like 15 minutes.
The idea behind
Heads Up Hands Free
is you just walk by a place,
tap, you get the information,
you move on--
no phone required, at
least not looking at it.
Now, it's a really
cool concept I think,
and a bunch of our apps use
that as its guiding principle.
It's not a must, but
it's a design philosophy,
and some of the developers
have been really
clever about implementing it.
So the way that it
works is the sensors--
actually, the data gets
sent to the mobile app,
so the wearable has to work with
a mobile phone, iOS or Android,
and that goes for the frames
and the headphones as well.
So some of the products
that work with it
are the frames, for example,
which you all have here.
I'm going to show just a
little brief intro in frames.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
(SINGING) I look good.
Good, good.
Say, I look good.
This is sunshine
dripping down my face.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So the frames were
actually a concept
that came out of our
San Francisco office,
so it's a very different
kind of idea behind it.
I, personally, think
it's a super cool idea.
I think frames are a really
great outdoor wearable.
It's great while you're
biking, for example, when you
don't want to be interrupted.
If you don't want to--
let's say you get a call.
You could just pick up
straight through the frames.
You don't have to
pull out your phone.
Or you could do
turn-by-turn navigation.
Again, you don't have to
be mounting your phone,
putting a waterproof
case or whatever.
You just have your frames on.
Also, it doesn't
plug up your ears.
It's open ear audio,
so you can still
hear the sounds of
the street around you.
And it's not on the
safe in that way,
like wearing like noise
canceling headphones
while biking, for example.
I just realized I got to
do this QuickTime thing.
Maybe click there.
There we go.
Next up-- oh, skip that--
QC35 II's.
Now, this product you might
be more familiar with.
You've probably seen people
wearing these, usually
maybe on an airplane.
So this is the classic noise
canceling headphone which
also has Bose AR sensors in it.
And a lot of people
actually don't know that,
so I believe it's all the
models after October of 2018
were manufactured with
the Bose AR sensors in it.
And then the NC700's,
which are these--
so these are the brand
new noise canceling
headphones that just came out.
I get asked what's
the difference
between the QCs and the NCs.
There's a few.
Obviously, there's a redesign.
It looks a lot more modern.
It has a little bit more
of a sleek aesthetic.
I think that the QC35
have a very dad road trip
look to them, especially
the gray ones.
But yeah, it's a
brand new redesign,
and one of the main upgrades,
I'd say, is the microphone.
So for conference
calling, it actually
has a noise canceling
microphone because it
has eight beamforming mics.
So it can actually pick
up your voice as opposed
to the environment,
so I found it really
good in loud environments.
They've actually done comparison
tests in a loud environment,
and you can barely hear
anything in the background
while you're talking with them.
So I personally really
like that because I
do a lot of conference calls in
sometimes noisy environments.
There's a little promo video
associated with that, too,
if you want to see.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
And these are the first
product that was--
the first Bose product that has
been marketed with the Bose AR
features in it.
So the whole idea
behind the NCs is,
again, the Heads Up Hands Free.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FILIP BABA: So I
don't know if you
saw near the end of the video,
but there's a little capacitive
touch screen here on the side.
So it's not touch
screen, it's a touch--
AUDIENCE: Surface.
FILIP BABA: Surface, yeah.
And it's, yeah, you can
do volume up and down,
skip track, or go back.
And then there's
also touch and hold,
which you can actually get
as a gesture inside Bose AR
when you're building your app.
So again, the whole
idea is, you're not
pulling out your phone.
You have your wearable,
your AR-enabled wearable,
which is your headphones, which
you carry around with you.
If you're like me, I
carry around my headphones
everywhere.
So you can talk to your
Google Assistant or to Siri
through it, receive messages.
It'll actually read out
the messages to you.
So again, the whole idea is to
have this wearable be pretty
much your main input
and output device
for your daily mobile uses.
So one of our
projections is that we're
going to have one million
AR devices in 2019
across all three of the
products that I just showed you.
Now, that's actually
really huge,
because most AR is
single purpose AR.
If you get a hololens,
it's more enterprise.
You're not really going to
be wearing it out on the bus,
you know.
Or a Magic Leap,
same thing, they only
work in certain environments.
It can't be in bright sunlight.
And AR, typically,
is a very niche thing
that's found in specific
places for specific use cases.
But the idea behind Bose
AR is that these wearables
are actually being worn
by people every day,
already, just for
their regular life,
to listen to music, to do
their conference calls.
But now we have this AR
platform built into it as well.
And developers can
actually leverage
a very big install base.
Because there's a lot of
these devices out there.
And they're
constantly being sold
and the user base is growing.
And they're going to be looking
for Bose AR enabled apps.
Well, what can I run
on these new headphones
that I just bought?
So we have an iOS and
Android native SDK.
And then we also
have a Unity plug-in,
which is what we're
going to be using today,
which actually works with
both iOS and Android.
So I'm just going to go
into a few of the use
cases, a few of the
apps that are here,
that might be a little
bit inspiring so you
can kind of get an idea
of what people are doing.
So Otocast is a really
cool concept behind, like,
how you can--
let's say you're at
a music festival.
They could set up a
tour where you actually
hear these audio pings.
So if there's a point of
interest as you're walking by,
you'll just hear, like,
a spatial audio pinging.
And it's very unobtrusive, it's
not like it's yelling at you.
Hey, there's the thing here.
It's just kind of
like, it's a ping.
And then if you
look at that ping,
you can actually
double tap to enter it.
And it'll tell you,
oh, this is this stage.
Or maybe if you're doing
like a historical tour,
it'll tell you this
is this landmark,
would you like to
enter this tour?
And then you enter it.
And then you can go
and actually explore
and it'll kind of tell you
what these environments are.
Walc is kind of a
similar concept,
also to Otocast and Naviguide.
And Naviguide, I
explained earlier.
It's kind of like you're using
a gesture to Yelp things,
basically.
So it's really cool to kind
of, like, not bring you out
of your travel experience.
You're just kind of
walking, and exploring,
and getting information
you need without, again,
staring at your phone.
So all of these kind of use
initially in the sensors
what I said.
So you the GPS from
the mobile device.
And then you use the magnetic
heading from the wearable.
And what's really cool
about using magnetic heading
from the frames, people
always wear their sunglasses
perpendicular.
It's not like your phone, where
the magnetometer sometimes--
you ever use the map
and you're trying
to look at the compass on
the map, and it's opposite,
or it's not very accurate?
And you got to,
like, do this and you
got to recalibrate your phone.
So with the frames,
it's actually
a lot better because
you're never really putting
that in a wrong direction.
It's always kind of
facing perpendicular.
So it's really good
to get a heading.
Sport and wellness,
so another use case
is some of these sport apps.
So Golfshot's actually
a really great example.
People wear frames when
they're out on the golf course.
It's sunglasses, they might
be listening to music as well,
so it's a perfect fit.
So Golfshot's an
already established app
that golfers use
to get information
about but their shot, and
their stored game details.
I'm not much of a
golfer so I don't really
know all the details.
But I do know that they have
a Bose AR enabled feature that
actually allow you to
measure things like distance
to the next hole, again, without
having to pull out your phone
and typing in some information.
It uses all the data
from the sensors
and from the mobile device.
It knows where you are, it
knows what course you're on.
And then you can have this
seamless experience, again,
without pulling out your phone.
You're just already
wearing some glasses
because you're playing golf,
and it's sunny, and you know.
Yeah, I hope I makes sense.
So New Balance I think
is a really cool one.
This is a demo.
So they kind of created
more of a workout app.
It's kind of like a
motivational workout app, where
it'll count your sets and reps.
So think, like,
you're doing sit ups
and you're actually doing
that custom gesture.
And you're counting how
many sit ups you did.
And it gives you
positive feedback,
oh, you're doing great, two
more, or something like that.
So again, if you
weren't doing heads up,
hands free, maybe you'd
be checking your phone
to see how many you've done.
There's really no way to
kind of do it seamlessly
unless you're kind of wearing
a little extra piece of sensors
on you.
Headspace is also a demo.
And this is actually
getting a big revamp.
But the idea behind this,
it's a meditation app.
So it's a perfect fit for
things like spatial audio.
They even have a little bit of
an exercise you kind of like
stretch your neck.
And then again, it's
using the sensors
in the wearable to
actually be able to tell
if you did your neck stretch.
Then when you do
your neck stretch,
it kind of has this
soothing voice.
It's like, all right, so now,
we're going to close our eyes
and, you know.
And it starts to play
a little soundscape.
And it helps you
kind of meditate.
Another idea I heard brought
up is, you can actually
check someone's posture.
So if someone's falling asleep,
you can kind of slightly
ping them to wake up,
so things like that.
Like I said, developers have
been really creative with it.
And then music of
course, I think
music is one of
the best use cases.
Because I think
spatial audio, which
is what today's workshop is
mainly going to be about,
is a very unexplored area of
music or sound in general.
And Bose AR is a perfect
fit for spatial audio,
especially because of the
sensors that I was just
mentioning because you
know the head orientation,
you can actually simulate
spatial audio just
between the two stereo speakers.
You can actually blend
the sound between
based on where your
head is looking.
So Radar is a great
example of this.
So Radar is an app built by
Bose, which actually connects
to something that's called
Creator Tool that's currently
in development.
It's in closed beta.
But the idea here
is that Radar is
going to be kind of almost like
a marketplace slash area where
you can browse lots of different
spatial audio experiences.
And they're going to be tied
to certain areas on the map.
So maybe if you're
in a certain place,
there's certain spatial
audio experiences
that wouldn't be in
some other place.
And it can do things like
it can ping you when you
enter, let's say, some park.
And maybe there's a
spatial audio experience
tied to that park.
And you'll be able to enter
it if you just kind of have
the app running
in the background.
Traverse is a cool example
of a mixture between RAPI
and existing ARAPI.
So I think they're using ARKit.
And what it actually
allows you to do,
it's kind of like you're
in the middle of a concert.
And you're hearing the different
instruments playing around you.
So what you can actually
do is, while you're
holding your phone up, you
can actually kind of close
your eyes you just
walk around the room.
And you're actually exploring
all the different instruments
around you.
You can walk up to the singer,
you can walk up to the piano.
And it's using ARKit to do
positional tracking and Bose AR
for spatial audio and
your head orientation.
So it's actually using
both the phone's positional
and the head's
rotational tracking.
And it knows between the two.
And it kind of simulates
as if you're actually
in the middle of a band or
a concert that's playing.
iHeartRadio is a cool
demo app, I'd say.
It's basically another
take on how you can tune
in to different radio channels.
So instead of pulling out
your phone and seeking,
you're actually using
your head orientation.
And you're kind of, like,
your head's the tuner.
And then when you like
something you just
kind of double tap
and you go into it.
And then you can pull out
of it at any time and tune
into something else.
And if you get a little
preview and you like it,
you tap into it and
you're listening to it
without having to look at
oh, I'm 22.3 FM, or whatever.
You're just kind
of listening to it.
Games is predominantly in
the realm of our Unity SDK.
So we have some cool games
that have been built.
The three that I
have up here are
what I would call
representative experiences.
So we actually have a lot more
games that have been built,
especially this year.
And I'll show you actually
some videos of the games
to kind of get inspired.
So all these games
are actually out.
So you can download
them on the App Store
if you have a Bose
AR enabled wearable.
And like I said, they're
representative experiences.
Meaning that I believe
these developers kind of
created some design
patterns out of these.
They were one of the first
to make games for it.
And I think these three are
kind of in their own category.
So OverHerd, it's a
really funny game.
You basically play
as an Englishman
that's taunted by Frenchmen
at castles at night.
It's very kind of, like,
Monty Python-esque.
Funny accents, the voice
acting is hilarious.
And what you do is you use
your head as, like, a catapult.
And your head
orientation like this.
And you double tap
and you basically
launch cows into these castles.
And you kind of hear the moo.
And it's all spatial.
So you're kind of listening
for where they're at.
And when you're
turning your head,
you hear the castles over there.
And then the Frenchmen
are, like, taunting you.
Like, oh, I bet you can't
hit the broad side of a barn,
or whatever.
I'm not going to try to do the
accent, but you should hear it.
It's pretty hilarious.
And it's a great
example of, it's
kind of using the spatial audio
and using your head orientation
as the controller, basically.
So Komrad is a cool
design pattern.
So it's basically
like a spy novel.
And it's a choose your
own adventure spy novel.
So you can actually make
decisions in the story.
So the story goes on and there's
yes and no decision trees
that you go through.
And at some point I
think you have to duck
and dodge a bullet.
And it's got this
whole AI theme to it.
And the AI's talking to you
and you're making decisions.
And you kind of change
the outcome of the story.
So that's a pretty popular
design pattern, and one
that I'm a huge fan of.
I love choose your
own adventure games.
And I think the medium
is perfect for it.
Instead of just doing
yes or no on the screen,
you can actually do yes and
no by nodding and shaking
your head.
So it's very immersive.
When you get asked a
question you're like, yes.
And then it kind of goes on.
Dead Drop Desperado
is a multiplayer game.
It's a local multiplayer game.
So what I actually really
like about this one
is it's got a little bit of a
party game kind of aesthetic
to it.
So you play with a friend.
And one of you holds the
mobile phone and the other one
gets handed off the wearable,
so let's say the headphones.
And what happens is he's
standing in front of you.
And you shoot bullets
at your friend.
And your friend is trying
to dodge the bullets
by listening to
where they're coming
from using the spatial audio.
And you're kind of leaning
left and right like that.
And then it gets switched off.
And then you're the
one who's dodging,
and he's the one
that's shooting.
And then in the end, there's
kind of a score tally
and it's got a leaderboard.
And it kind of has a little bit
of a competitive aspect to it.
What I personally like
is that you could,
let's say, you have
your headphones,
and you want to show someone
something cool on them.
You could just kind of
hand off the headphones.
And now it's this
multi-player interaction.
So you have the headphones,
I have the phone.
And you switch it up.
And it's also a
little bit competitive
with the leaderboard and such.
So like I said,
representative experiences.
You're definitely not limited
to these design patterns.
We're actually excited to see
what our developers come up
with.
And there's always cool stuff
that people come up with.
And I just wanted to
show you a little bit.
So we have this video
that was produced.
So we've posted a bunch
of game jams this year.
And this is one of the first
game jams that we hosted.
And these games that
I just showed you
were actually built at it.
So I'll just go
ahead and show you.
So this is from our
Playcrafting partnership.
Playcrafting is a small,
game developer collective.
But plus they also host
events like Play NYC.
And they bring developers,
they teach Unity classes,
and they just have a general
kind of game developer
community across the country.
So we've partnered with them to
have some of these Bose AR game
jams.
And I'll show you the video.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ERIC HAMEL: We're here this
weekend at Bose's offices
in Boston.
And we're doing a game jam
with their new AR technology.
MICHAEL LUDDEN: We've
given the developers
a brand new version of the
Bose AR SDK and Unity plugin.
It allows Unity developers to
use and add Bose AR integration
to Unity based apps.
REJON TAYLOR-FOSTER: They've
built a very intuitive system
for developers like me to be
able to just pop it into Unity
and just go.
MICHAEL CARRIER:
We give you access
to all of the sensors that
are available in the device,
the accelerometer,
the gyroscope, two
different rotation sensors.
They provide orientation of the
user's head and world space.
We can actually provide
spatialized audio,
which just gives you an entirely
new level of context when
you're making any
sort of experience.
ERIC CHAN: We're able to get
all sorts of different types
of information from the
frames glasses, which
we can use to help develop
the new types of interactions.
ERIC HAMEL: We were challenged
to create an augmented reality
experience that put audio first.
ANNA SHABAYEV: It's
very interesting
to look at games from, like,
a whole different angle.
JONATHAN SHRACK: Usually
people think AR and think,
oh, it's all visual.
And this one, it's
Bose, so it's audio.
CRAIG HERNDON: The
challenge really
made us put our heads
together and be like,
what can you really do?
ANNA SHABAYEV: There's
a whole world of sound.
And we shouldn't just
be paying attention
to just the visual component.
MICHAEL LUDDEN: So we've had
a lot of really creative ideas
that the developers have
come up with so far.
And I think some of the
more interesting aspects
are the different game mechanics
with the user interface
experiments that they're doing.
MIKE LEVINE: The
game we created,
we're calling sonic samurai.
You're the samurai
and you can't see.
But there are all these
monsters around you.
And you basically have to use
the Bose headset to determine
where the monsters are.
And then you actually
use your mobile device
as your sword to
strike at the monsters.
REJON TAYLOR-FOSTER: It's a
game where you essentially
try to dodge bullets that are
sent from one user towards you.
Imagine the matrix, but
you can't see the bullets
that are coming at you.
You can only hear them.
MARC HARPIN: Our game
is called OverHerd.
ERIC HAMEL: You play a
medieval catapult operator,
catapulting poultry and
cows as French castles.
MARC HARPIN: You're
doing this all at night,
under cover of darkness.
ERIC HAMEL: So you
have to use your ears
to hear where the castle is.
MARC HARPIN: When
you point your frames
in the correct direction, you
can hear the French defenders
taunting you.
ERIC HAMEL: Daring you
throw things at them.
FRENCHMAN 1: Your
efforts are all wastes
of perfectly good livestocks.
MARC HARPIN: By turning your
head and elevating it up,
you actually modulate the angle
the catapult with fire at.
ERIC CHAN: You are being
bombarded by vegetables
in a 360 degree radius.
You can tell what direction
the vegetables are coming from
based on spatial audio.
And you need to find and
face the correct vegetable
and eat it.
JONATHAN SHRACK: We're working
on kind of a spy thriller game.
CRAIG HERNDON: When you
put on the Bose frames,
you start to get radio
chatter from a secret agent.
And you start doing instructions
to locate radar pings,
diffuse bombs.
Like James Bond and Mission
Impossible in real life.
WOMAN 1: Duck now.
ERIC CHAN: Augmented
reality is really
one of the most important
future mediums for design.
MICHAEL CARRIER: And we're
getting the tools set up
in a way that allow people
to start experimenting.
And using something like
Unity allows that iteration
to happen very, very quickly.
REJON TAYLOR-FOSTER:
It's an honor
to be chosen to be here
to work on this technology
for the first time.
ANNA SHABAYEV: And also give
developers a bigger idea of,
like, what's possible
with this stuff so
that they can use our games as a
stepping stone for what's next.
DAN BUTCHKO: Here we
are at PAX East 2019.
All five of these games are
debuting for the first time
anywhere.
ERIC HAMEL: People are having
a lot of fun here this weekend.
Lots of people dodging
vegetables and throwing cows.
MAN 1: I always
enjoy, like, finding
new games that are innovative.
MAN 2: I've never
played anything just
based entirely on sound.
WOMAN 2: I don't think
I've seen anything
else here that relies completely
on audio and motion, no visual
at all.
But it felt really
immersive and cool.
IAN CUBIN: People are
really getting a sense
that the audio is
read and spatial.
WOMAN 3: You felt like
you're really there.
MAN 3: It's just a whole
different experience.
WOMAN 4: It's more social.
It really brings us back
to where games really are,
where it's with other people.
MAN 3: It's a fun
ride, these glasses.
DAN BUTCHKO: We're changing
the landscape of AR
and games in America.
And this is just a
taste of what's to come.
CRAIG HERNDON: It's
very exciting for us
to have that chance to
impact other people's
lives with a new technology.
CHUCK FREEDMAN: The
things that people
were able to do over a
weekend really inspired me
to think we're going to see
some amazing stuff this year.
FILIP BABA: And we have actually
seen some pretty amazing stuff
this year.
I feel like the more of
these experiences get built,
and the more developers
get creative with it,
it's an early
platform so there's
plenty of room to kind of
set the standard at what
could be created.
What else do I have here?
So I have a few actual
gameplay footage
that I'd like to show
you on some experiences
that I personally like.
Developers cut up these
videos to kind of show
what the games are like.
So just going to get into these.
And again, just some
more inspiration.
NARRATOR 1: The Worst
Grim Reaper's Soulmates
it's an AR music game.
FILIP BABA: That's this t-shirt.
NARRATOR 1: In which a singing
grim reaper plays a song that
responds to you and your world.
The grim reaper
Sebastian is a character
from another one of our games.
He's tired of his dead
end job collecting souls
and wants to pursue his
dream of being a songwriter.
Seeking inspiration,
Sebastian asks
you to let him write a
song about your life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SEBASTIAN: (SINGING) You looking
up, maybe lost in thought,
kind of like me, you
know I daydream a lot.
There are things on the
ceiling and in outer space.
There's magic in
almost every place.
Hey, would you like to
share you thoughts with me?
Wanting to learn about the
inside of the human skull.
I ask what's going
on in your soul.
OK, mm, are you maybe
thinking about food?
I still have a lot to
learn about human kind.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
SEBASTIAN: Would
be on their minds.
OK, so if it's not
spaghetti or chocolate cake.
So maybe the fact that the
sun will someday explode
and everything we know will
go up in an ocean of flames?
The human mind is less
dark than I would guessed.
I'll try to see inside
of you once more.
Hm, oh, is it someone you like?
As in, like like?
NARRATOR 1: Imagine
players using this app
while commuting and
exploring or just relaxing.
Through interacting with
Sebastian and his song,
we want to show players that
even the smallest things
in life can carry meaning.
Sometimes we just need
someone to talk to.
FILIP BABA: Cool, right?
It actually works.
It's actually really fun.
So one of the things
that I personally
have learned over overdoing
some of these jams
and seeing what
developers build is
that when you're not focusing
so much on the visuals,
you have a lot of room
for story and substance,
if I could say it so myself.
It's like this developer,
was we had all teams of four.
So three of those people
were just content creators.
So one we brought was Mitty.
He was he was actually
producing music during the jam.
One was just doing like the
singing and the voice acting.
I forget what the
third guy was doing.
I think he was doing, like, UI.
Even though I do recommend
to have nice, polished UI.
But it doesn't have to be
crazy, that's the thing.
Like most games are very 3D.
And one of the things
that's a problem,
I'm a game developer myself,
nowadays there's so many tools
and so many things
you can do, it's
kind of hard to figure
out what you want to do.
Because you're like,
oh my god, just
overwhelmed with
all these things
that our modern devices can do.
So there's a lot of room
for this kind of content
to be produced.
So this is kind of like a little
AI kind of companion game,
you could say.
And yeah, it responds.
And there's other things he
didn't mention in the video.
Like, it actually changes
based on the weather.
So it actually
checks the weather.
If it's a rainy day,
you start the game,
you'll have a rainy day mood.
If it's a sunny day, you'll
have a sunny day mood.
So it's kind of a
replayable thing.
And I don't expect people
to be running this app,
like, nonstop.
But I could probably
see people running
this for that one hour of
their commute during the day,
or maybe like for their
lunch break or something
like that, which is actually
a lot, in terms of mobile app
usage.
So it's fun.
And it's music,
so you're probably
already listening to music.
Why not have a soundtrack
to your life, for example?
That's kind of the
idea behind the game.
This one is also a
really cool example.
So I'll just let him explain it.
NARRATOR 2: That is about
bopping and grooving
your head to the music.
Similar to other rhythm
games, you score points
by staying on the beat.
At the moment, we have about
a dozen custom written songs.
In the future, we want the
possibility for players
to download hundreds of songs
or play with their own music
library.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We are going to play Party
in the Washing Machine.
Our foxy friend here is
grooving along as well.
You could follow it and he
helps you stay on the beat.
The line below is showing
your head movements.
It also changes colors to
indicate how long you're doing.
So we really intend
this game to be
a phone in pocket experience.
We added both audio
and tactile feedback.
For example, the
high pass filter
turns on when you're doing bad.
And your phone vibrates with the
beat when you're doing great.
So the idea of Hip
Hop Hero came from us
wanting to make a game that
naturally played with Bose AR
defenses, something you
can play while commuting
on the train in public.
FILIP BABA: Yeah, it's
like a play on words
of Guitar Hero, kind of.
You know, you're kind
of staying on the beat.
You get rated based on how well
you did, how well on the beat
you stayed.
And you don't have to have
a specific head gesture.
It's just kind of how you
would normally bob your head.
And they have a
pretty good algorithm
for detecting that change.
They're using both the
accelerometer and the gyro,
but I'm not I'm not
100% sure on that.
But yeah, I thought it was great
how they visualized it as well.
So that's an actual graph
based on your head movement.
And then you get rated
and, you know, it's yeah.
I mean, you've probably
seen games like this.
And this is the last one.
This one I like
because you're kind
of producing music in a way.
Now, it's basically song
loops that they've created.
But the amount of song
loops that are in this app,
for example,
I mean, someone
here can probably
do the mathematical permutations
of how many combinations
of unique songs you
can get out of it.
But it's a lot when you include,
like, 10 loops, for example,
for bass lines, as you're kind
of adding complexity to a song.
And if you have maybe, like, 10
of each samples and in the end
you got, like, maybe
40 samples in total,
you could be creating unique
music on every play through.
NARRATOR 3: Choose your own
adventure musical experience
of layering song loops,
set in a world where
flowers produce music.
Players listen,
explore, and nod along
to the music, collecting
song loops like pollen,
in order to blossom
a musical garden.
The game is played by looking
around to find new sounds,
and nodding your head
along to the beat when
you find one you like.
This process can
go on indefinitely,
allowing players to explore
countless new ways of layering
together song tracks.
FILIP BABA: It's basically, she
totally nailed the explanation,
like, in the beginning.
But basically, yeah,
you look around.
You hear a preview of
a loop, you like it.
You nod it.
And then you go on, and
you're just layering loops.
And it works really well.
I mean, the developer really
figured out a way to make it.
If you've ever
tried to make music,
sometimes you could
just mess up and it just
sounds terrible because you're
mixing way too many dissonant
sounds.
But they managed to figure
out an algorithm to layer it
and it always sounds good.
And I've tried to break it.
Whenever I play any
of these experiences,
I'm pressing everywhere
and nodding to everything,
trying to make it sound bad.
And I couldn't.
It always sounded good.
So super cool.
So that's our developer portal.
It Developer.Bose.com/BoseAR.
That's where you'll
find the SDK.
I'm sure most of you
have already gone on here
and downloaded it.
But I'll show you where
all that is in a sec.
And the last kind of, like,
but not least important thing
that I wanted to say.
So we have a new program that
we just launched recently,
and that's Bose
AR Certification.
So what Bose AR
Certification is,
is say you build a Bose
AR app and you submit it
for certification.
Our internal team
will actually help
you get across the finish line
and publish the app to the App
Store or the Android
Store, making sure you have
all the right requirements.
And then if it
does get certified,
and it's within our brand
guidelines, which again, we'll
kind of help you get
through that finish line,
you can get a possible
feature on the Bose Music
app or the Bose Connect app.
And you might even get
featured on the Bose website.
So it's a really great
showcase and a really great way
to get noticed, especially
as an early game developer.
It's an early platform,
so obviously we're
looking for great content
to feature on our portals.
And if the content's
great, and it's, again,
passes the certification.
Which all these games
that I've shown you,
they're all in the process
of getting certified
and they'll all
be available when
you have your frames, for
example, when you hook them up
in the Bose connect app.
There's actually a section
there, Bose AR enabled apps.
And then you click
that and there's
a directory there of apps.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So this
works with Android now?
FILIP BABA: So it works on
Android as well, yes, it does.
AUDIENCE: OK.
FILIP BABA: We had a
little bit of a, like,
earlier start with iOS SDK.
So a lot of stuff
was mainly iOS.
AUDIENCE: In July it
wasn't working on Android.
FILIP BABA: Yeah, now
we're rectifying that.
There's going to be a lot of
Android experiences coming out.
Sadly, it's still, some
developers just build for iOS.
And we kind of
have to prod them.
Be like, hey, could you
also build an Android build?
And sometimes they need to
be incentivized to do that.
Other times they just do it.
If it's Unity, then most
of these experiences
are going to be on both.
But sadly, that's just kind of
how native app development is,
they sometimes just want to
work in one and not the other.
But we are fully Android
supported now as well.
And then we also have
a Get Inspired page.
This is a place where we have
some case studies written.
Golfshot's there, if you
want to read about it.
Dead Drop Desperado's
also up there.
I think OverHerd.
And it's just kind of a little
interview with the developers.
They kind of talk about
their process of developing.
And it's a good place to get
inspired and be like this guy,
really happy, like, ah.
Yeah, that's
basically the intro.
I hope that didn't
take too long.
But yeah, just wanted
to kind of give you
a little bit of an
understanding of what this is.
So does anyone have
any questions or no?
Good.
All right, so now
that we've gone
through that, what
I'm going to do here,
I'm just going to
close my Unity.
And let's go ahead and
actually fire up Unity.
And we're going to get our
a little beginner workshop
started.
So you should all have a
copy of the Unity package,
of the Bose AR SDK for
Unity, which you can find it
on our downloads page.
Let me know if you have
trouble finding that.
We're going to be
using this 4.0.1 beta.
And when you download that,
it's just a Unity package
that gets downloaded.
So I'm just going to let
everyone kind of get to that.
And the version of Unity
that I'm going to be using
is just the latest one.
I have 2019.2.5F1.
And I have Android and iOS
build support as modules in it.
And I recommend
that if you're going
to be building to mobile that
you have your desired platform
modules installed.
I'm just going to let
everyone go ahead and do that.
AUDIENCE: Hey,
should we tell them
that-- is it still that
iPhone is only VDM?
FILIP BABA: It's
always a thing, yeah,
it's just Apple and iPhone.
But again, if you don't
get a chance to build,
you'll still be able
to preview the app
and play with it directly
from your laptop.
For most of this
workshop, we're actually
going to be sticking to the
creative side of things,
and concept, and trying
to build an experience.
And then, like I
said, towards the end,
we'll try to make sure
that everyone has built.
And if you don't have
the right device,
I'm sure we have
some extra devices.
And if it comes to it, we could
potentially also build or maybe
share devices if needed.
But once you have it set up
once, then you're good to go.
I have my iPhone here.
I usually have to have both.
All right, everyone
got their SDK?
And ready to go.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to actually make
a new project in Unity.
And I'll just make sure everyone
has this before we do that.
I'm just going to do the latest.
And I'm just going to call
this project MIT Bose AR Unity
Workshop.
And I'm just going to pick
3D project and create.
Bless you.
Hm?
AUDIENCE: Isn't it stable core?
FILIP BABA: Yes it is.
I think I just missed a
little bit in the beginning.
All right, so I'm just going
to switch to the default layout
here.
Anyone not have their new
Unity project open yet?
All right, just take your time.
AUDIENCE: I'm
downloading [INAUDIBLE]..
FILIP BABA: Oh, well good
thing the internet's fast.
AUDIENCE: I'm using an early
version Unity right now.
FILIP BABA: How old?
What's the version?
AUDIENCE: 15.
FILIP BABA: That's fine.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: I'm
downloading the new one.
FILIP BABA: Anything
that's past the LTS,
the 2017.1.4 should be fine.
Anything with, like, an f at
the end of it, it's final,
not beta should work.
AUDIENCE: OK.
FILIP BABA: If for
whatever reason
it doesn't, I know sometimes
there's been some edge cases.
But it should be fine.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
So when you do have
this, I just want
you to take that Unity
package that was downloaded
and just click it or
double click it to open it.
And you'll get an import dialog.
And I just want you to
import the entire thing
into your project.
Everyone imported?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, what do
you click to import again?
FILIP BABA: You should just
be able to double click
the Unity package.
And it should just
pull up Unity.
If for whatever reason
that doesn't work,
you can always right
click in your project
here and then Import
Package, Custom Package.
That also works as a backup.
AUDIENCE: Yours is
a CSC file, right?
I have an MCS file.
So--
FILIP BABA: For what?
AUDIENCE: Just for the assets.
FILIP BABA: Oh, yeah.
Don't worry about that.
Everyone imported, ready to go?
Give it another minute.
So yeah, when you import
the Unity package,
you get the entirety of the SDK.
There's samples in
here, sample scenes.
There's a lot of cool stuff
in here that I'll get into.
And the setup itself
is actually really
straightforward and simple.
We've tried to make
this as easy as possible
to either put into a new project
or integrate with an existing
project.
So if you're
familiar with Unity,
or if you've worked on
a Unity project before,
you'll find that a
lot of the, I guess,
the user flow and the
way that the SDK works
is typical, kind of
to a Unity workflow.
So once you're all
imported, you'll
see these three folders show up.
So the first one that I want you
to look at is the Bose folder.
So you go inside the Bose
folder, there's wearable.
And then inside wearable,
there's modules.
You go to modules.
And the first module that
we want is connection.
So we're going to go to
connection and then prefabs.
So that's Bose, wearable,
modules, connection, prefabs.
And I want you to pull in this
first prefab that's available
here.
So just drag that
into your scene.
You should see this
white rectangle pop up.
Now, the first thing
that I like to do
when I start a Unity project,
especially if I'm developing
on mobile, is I
like to pull my game
view, which is usually up here.
You might have a
different layout.
And I actually like
to take the game view,
and I like to make it visible.
So I actually drag that
game view over here
to the right side of
the project panel.
So I always kind of have a
little preview window here
of what my preview
looks like, basically.
So if you go ahead and
do that, then you'll
see that the panel that
we just pulled in actually
shows up here.
And I'll explain what the
wearable connect panel does.
It's basically the
entire menu that
shows up that you can browse
all available devices.
You click a device,
and you connect to it.
So this handles all of
the connection for you.
There's some cool
features on here,
like auto reconnect and such.
So for example, if
during your app,
for example, maybe Bluetooth
connection turns off,
or for whatever reason
the battery runs out,
this panel will pop up again.
It'll say, you've
been disconnected,
searching for device
to kind of like
keep the user experience clean.
So you have the wearable
connect UI panel.
And the next thing
that we actually
need to make the wearable
connect UI panel work
is we need an event system.
So what I want you
to do is I actually
want you to just
create an empty game
object somewhere in the scene,
and call it event system.
And on that empty
game object, I'm
going to Add Component
here in the Inspector.
And I'm just going to
start typing, event system.
There it is.
It's a built in Unity thing.
And once you have
your event system,
there's a button there called
add default input modules.
So just click that.
Now, I'll explain
what this does.
This actually
allows you to click
the UI of the connect panel.
Now, the reason why
we do this separate
is, maybe you have an already
existing Unity project.
And maybe you already
have your own event system
that you've set up, so we
don't want to mess with that.
But since we're
starting a new project,
we're going to create
this event system
and add the default
input modules.
Like I said, that just allows
you to actually click the UI
and select the panel.
So that's pretty much it.
The last piece that we
need to actually set up,
like our entire Bose AR,
is we actually go in.
And we're going to create
another empty object.
And we're going to call
this one wearable control.
Now, this will actually stream
the sensor data back and forth
from our app.
So wearable control.
And I'm going to add component.
Now, if you clear
the search here,
I'm just going to show you
where the Bose components are.
So when you clear
the search, there
is a Bose subcategory here.
And you can click
Bose, wearable.
And we have some sample
scripts here that you can use.
So the one that we want
is wearable control.
We're just going to click that.
Now, one other useful thing that
we added semi-recently is you
can actually go up into here.
So if you go to asset,
for assets, create.
And then there's a
Bose wearable category
and there's an app
intent profile.
So I'm actually going to
take that app intent profile.
I'm going to put that
in my top directory
in assets, because I was
in the prefabs folder here.
You don't have to, but
it's just cleaner that way.
And what you'll see
here on the right
is you'll actually
see the sensors that
are available to us.
So for this first app
that we're building,
we just need the gyroscope.
So I'm going to check
the gyroscope on here.
And rotation, 6th off.
And then the update interval,
I'm going to make it,
let's say, 40 milliseconds.
That's all we kind of
need in terms of sensors.
And what this basically does
is it just kind of syncs up
what the app
requirements are and what
the app is going to be using.
So back to our wearable control
that we created earlier.
You'll see there's an active app
intent profile empty slot right
here.
You can actually just
click that and just
pull in that app intent
profile that we just created.
So again, that's App Intent
Profile is in assets.
Create Bose wearable
App Intent Profile.
In the App Intent
Profile, you want
to select Gyroscope,
RotationSixDof,
and 40 milliseconds.
And then in Wearable
Control, just put
that App Intent Profile there.
The last step to get
this to actually work
is, where it says
Editor Default Provider,
it says Debug Provider.
We're actually going to
switch that to USB Provider.
And what that will
actually allow us to do
is it will actually allow us to
send the data over USB bridge
directly to Unity, which
is great for debugging
while you're developing.
So that's actually what we're
going to be doing first.
So your Wearable Control
has a USB provider.
And that's pretty much it.
So your app will actually
now connect, both using USB
and, if you built this
to Android or iOS,
you'll actually be able
to pair it with Bluetooth.
The only problem is we're not
getting any of the sensor data.
So we're not actually
doing anything with it yet.
So the first thing
that I want to do
is, let's say I just want
to visualize the head
orientation on the screen.
So how do we do that?
So what we're
going to do here is
I actually want you to
go back to the Modules.
And in here there's another
folder called Model Loader
and Prefabs.
So if you go to Bose, Wearable,
Modules, Model Loader Prefabs,
in here you'll
actually see we have
a 3D model of all of our
Bose AR enabled wearables,
which is actually really cool.
And then there's also
a default for if it
doesn't know or maybe
for a future product
or something like that.
So the Wearable Model
Loader actually pulls up
the appropriate
model automatically,
so it knows which
one you're doing.
But right now let's
just do it manually.
So pull up the
one that you have.
So I have Rondo's here.
So I'm just going to
take the Rondo's prefab,
and I'm just going to
drag it into my scene.
And if I double click it,
you'll see it's very small.
So I would recommend
to scale it up,
let's say, to something
like 40 by 40 by 40.
So we just have our Rondo's
like that in the scene.
And the last thing
that I want to do
is on this prefab I actually
want to Add Component.
And in here we're going
to go to Bose, Wearable,
and then there's a script
called Rotation Matcher.
So we're going to
select that, and we're
going to make the update
interval 40 milliseconds.
OK?
So what Rotation Matcher does
is what the name implies.
It will match the
rotation of the wearable,
so it will actually
take the gyroscope data.
And that's actually
pretty much it.
So this should already work.
So what we're going to
do is we're actually
going to test it out.
So what I want you to do is I
want you to take your frames.
Hook them up with
USB to your computer.
If you're on Windows, you'll
hear the connected sound.
And I'm actually just going
to Maximize on Play here
so you can see what I'm doing.
I'm going to press Play.
The picker is there.
I have my frames I
selected in the UI.
It's going to connect to it.
And there are my frames tracking
their rotation as intended.
AUDIENCE: And this is
all happening over USB,
so if the cable disconnects--
FILIP BABA: Yep.
It'll stop, yeah.
So the idea is that
this is for development.
You're obviously going
to be using the cable.
But if you took this app
and actually built it
to your phone, it would
work over Bluetooth.
AUDIENCE: OK.
FILIP BABA: So I want everyone
to just get to this point,
and then we'll move
on to the next part.
And what's really cool
about this is we're
already pretty much
just a few steps away
from doing spatial audio.
Now that we have the
head orientation,
we can actually move our point
of reference for the listener.
AUDIENCE: So when
you plug in USB,
does it automatically
just detect it?
FILIP BABA: It should
be plug and play, yeah.
Does it work for you?
AUDIENCE: It's not connecting.
FILIP BABA: So make sure you
have the Wearable Control
script.
So you skipped this step.
So you have to have the
Wearable Control script.
So what you want
to do is you want
to create an Empty Game Object.
AUDIENCE: Oh yes, I do have it.
FILIP BABA: Yeah,
wearable control.
There it is.
Click it.
Oh, so event system--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
FILIP BABA: Yeah.
So On Press Play.
Yeah, stop the app.
And then Add Default
Input Modules.
There you go.
Now you can press Play.
And you should be able to
click the UI at this time.
So yeah, there it is.
So let's then try to update.
AUDIENCE: I mean, it
might be faster just
to swap it with another--
FILIP BABA: I think
it's something
that we've also been
told to do, is people
should know how to
update the firmware.
So if for whatever reason
it's just not working,
chances are sometimes that you
just need the latest update.
So where you find
that is if you just
look up Bose Updater,
if you just Google it,
it's btu.bose.com.
Just try to follow those steps.
It's usually pretty fast.
You just download
the little tool,
and it's all through online.
So you just have it hooked
up, and it'll pick it up.
So if I try it on mine
here, it looks like this.
I'm going to connect my frames.
And see, it sees it.
There's an update
ready for my product.
And you just click Update Now,
and it'll do it in a minute.
If yours is working, you
don't have to do that.
But if for whatever
reason it doesn't, that's
usually the problem.
It has an old version
of the firmware.
If you need to know
how to turn them off,
you actually just
flip them upside down
when you put them on
the table, and they'll
turn off after a few seconds.
Bless you.
If you get the failed
connection, usually
reconnecting the device works.
It's just a USB debugger thing.
So I'm actually playing the
sound through my Bose frames.
So when you connect
over USB, you
can actually drive the
audio also through you USB.
Now on Mac, you'll see it pop
up in your sound settings.
And on Windows, it's
in the bottom right
in the sound devices.
You can set the Bose frames
as your default audio device.
So it's a great way
to preview it with.
Now, what I did here is I
placed the sound on this sphere.
Now, this sphere is just in
the middle of my field of view
here.
But in the next
exercise, I'm going
to actually show you
how to spatialize
that sound so you can hear it.
So I'm just going
to wait to make sure
that everyone's got this far.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
FILIP BABA: All right, so
what we're going to do here--
there are a couple
of ways to do this.
So typically your camera is your
frame of reference for audio.
So as your camera turns, if you
have 3D sounds in the scene,
it's going to take
the frame of reference
from your camera to
spatialize sound.
So what we want to
do here is I'm just
going to actually
take the camera that's
staring at the glasses.
Now you don't have
to do it like this.
There's a few different
ways to do it,
but we'll just do it
for simplicity's sake.
We'll take the main
camera, and we'll
pull them into our frames.
Now, the way I have
my scene set up
is my frames are just at 0,
0, 0, and they're scale 40.
And the camera is kind of like
right behind them like that.
So I'm just going to take
the main camera and parent it
to the frames so it's
inside the frames.
And if I press Play, I'll just
show you what that looks like.
So now if you're turning, this
is your frame of reference.
So this simulates your
orientation in space,
basically.
Right?
So here's how this
is going to work.
So in Unity, doing spatial
audio is actually really,
really straightforward.
So what I want you to do
is-- and I already did this,
so I'm just going to delete it
so I can show you how I did it.
It's very straightforward.
So it won't let me.
What is it, command?
There we go.
So what we're going
to do is I'm just
going to use a sphere to
represent a sound object just
for visual sake.
So I'm actually going to
create a New Game Object.
So 3D Object, Sphere.
And I'm going to
place it at 0, 0, 0.
I'm going to Add
Component to this sphere,
and I'm going to
add an Audio Source.
OK?
So that's a built
in Unity thing.
Now I take this
sphere, and let's say
this one I'm going to put
it in front of the glasses,
like here.
OK?
Maybe a little bit further.
And the audio source an audio
clip, if you click here,
there are a few
different sound samples
that we have in our SDK.
You could pick Chord
LP or something.
It's up to you which
one you want to pick.
This is just for the demo.
So we're going to
pick a sound effect.
We put it in front.
And the only thing you've got
to change is make it loop.
So there's a little
loop check mark here.
So when it finishes, it'll
start from the beginning again.
And then there's a dropdown
here called 3D Sound Settings.
I don't know if you see that.
We'll get to that in a second.
But the only one we want
to change is right here.
You see Spatial Blend?
OK.
So I'm actually going to drag
Spatial Blend from 2D to 3D.
And that's all you need to do to
turn an audio source into a 3D
audio source.
Now you'll notice that
there are cool things here,
like there's actually
the range of the sound
that you can tweak and stuff.
So we don't have to do
any of that just yet.
We can just leave it as is.
Just make sure it's 3D and
that you have a looping sound
effect.
And that's all I want
you to do right now.
So now if you press Play
and you let it connect--
mine has failed connecting.
If that ever happens
to you-- again,
it's just a known bug
that we have with USB--
just reconnect.
Make sure you're always
saving your scene
so no crashing happens.
Unity tends to do
that sometimes--
rarely, but usually it doesn't.
So yeah, if you get the
failed connecting thing,
just reconnect and
then try again.
So it did it again, so
I'm going to unpress play.
I'm going to reconnect.
It's something to do
with that it remembers
the previous device, and there's
a little bug with USB in that.
And connected.
So when I turn my head,
I can hear that sphere
in front of me.
And when I turn this
way, I hear it here.
Now I hear it on the left.
So in order to get that, make
sure you're driving your audio
through the Bose frames.
On Mac, you go into the
sound settings here.
And on Windows, I
can also show you--
in the bottom right where
the volume mixer is.
If it's saying
connecting to Pixel 2,
go into the Bose Connect
app and to the settings,
and you can actually
remove any previous device
that was there so it doesn't
always do that auto thing.
So there is a little
bit of a Doppler effect.
I don't know if you can
tell when you're doing that.
Right?
So these are all things you
can actually change here
in the 3D sound settings.
So I think if you just
turn off the Doppler,
it won't do that, I think.
So yeah, if you just go
into 3D sound settings
and you turn off
the Doppler, you
won't get that warp effect
when your head turns.
That is an interesting effect
that can be played with.
But again, this is just the
built-in Unity spatial audio.
We actually have a
couple of different ways
you can do spatial audio.
So we've gotten to the
point where you've set up
your device, you've gotten
a little bit of an intro,
you've seen what the
platform is about.
And this is basically a first
example of spatializing audio.
Right?
So now as an exercise what I'd
like you to do for the next 30
minutes or so-- or
let's say 20 minutes--
go online, find
some sound samples,
set up your own little
spatial soundscape around you.
And let's see how that goes.
AUDIENCE: So just loop them?
FILIP BABA: Yeah,
make something cool.
You can get some
beach sounds, maybe
water crashing on the
side, birds chirping.
Or it could be music samples.
Maybe you get a drum loop.
I could show you a few.
freesound.org is cool.
I believe it's freesound.org.
Yeah.
You need to make an
account, but it's free,
and it's all free sounds.
There are also a decent
amount of websites
that offer loops if you're going
for a more musical approach.
So yeah, go ahead and do that.
And let me know if you
have any questions.
I'll be going around
and helping you out.